[Music]
so Wendy you've asked the question do
electrons orbit around the nucleus of an
atom the same way planets orbit around a
star if you think about the way we
depict atoms in art we actually have the
nucleus in the center and then the
nucleus of course is where you find the
protons and neutrons and then we have
electrons in these circular rings around
the nucleus and sometimes in physics
they'll have the rings sort of as sort
of nested circles they're there they're
smaller circles and there are bigger
circles and we talk about electrons
jumping between those different orbits
calling what an electron is and where it
is around an atom in orbit is actually
very misleading in truth electrons don't
move around a nucleus the same way that
planets move around a star at all that's
very very different and part of that has
to do with what an electron really is
elementary particles are not tiny tiny
little balls that are actually moving
through space they're they're more
properly described as waves and an
electron does not exist in only one
location around an atom it actually
exists as a wave and what that means is
that there are volumes around the
nucleus of an atom that an electron will
fill in a single electron can actually
be an entire sphere around the nucleus
of an atom or these orbitals as we call
them but again I caution you nothing's
actually moving around like a planet
around a star some of these orbitals are
shaped like dumbbells and a single
electron actually fills out of volume
that looks like a dumbbell or sometimes
they look like a disk so these actually
are mathematical solutions which show
you where the probability of finding
this electron is around an atom we call
these electron shells and it's not that
a single electron is moving around
inside the shell it's in the whole shell
all at once the electron actually fills
in that volume and all you're looking at
is a probability area of where that
electron may be so there really isn't
any circular motion around an atom it's
true the electrons have angular momentum
they have something that we can actually
measure as spin but they're not actually
spinning they're not
she moving around you can sort of think
of them as clouds that can exist in
different locations around the nucleus
based on how much energy they have so
despite our depictions of atoms with you
know the nucleus in the middle and
electrons going around the outside
reality is nothing like that electrons
form these volumes and some of those
volumes even go through the nucleus some
of these dumbbells actually have
electrons existing inside the nucleus as
well what an atom really is is far more
complicated than our artistic depictions
of it far more mysterious and I think
really wonderful one of the one of the
the best things to study in quantum
mechanics is how electrons form these
volumes
[Music]